OOP and we will be working towards these
goals with my colleagues and the
merchants represented on the smart
working group and prohibits the sale and
distribution to any person in San
Francisco of flavored tobacco products
and electronic cigarettes that require
but have not yet received an FDA order
approving their marketing we spent the
90s battling Big Tobacco and now we see
its new form through e-cigarettes I'm
not gonna put profits of Big Tobacco
over the health of our children and our
young people the ordinance is not a
permanent ban it is a moratorium until
due diligence is carried out by the FDA
concerning big tobacco companies like
Jill's marketing to our youth companies
like Jill have had three years to submit
their product and marketing to the FDA
the question is why haven't they and the
answer is because they want to protect
their profits to continue targeting and
harming our young people and they know
nicotine is not healthy can we take
these items same house same call okay
without objection these ordinance are
passed on first reading unanimously
[Music]
never this is the amendment or you can
say if you have to get rid of it well
actually we are in shock because our
main business as a cigarette job is to
sell the e-cigarette and all kind of
tobacco product the kids are still
smoking and they're getting it not
through our small businesses here
actually they go online
like now in San Francisco we cannot sell
all kind of level or the e-cigarette but
you can go ten minutes drive south to
Delhi City or other state cities and you
can buy anything you want